hi steve kaufman here today and i want
to talk about why you do not need to be
perfect in any foreign language that
you're learning
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications
and if you follow me on a podcast
service please leave a review
so why do i want to talk about
perfection
first of all i am a dilettante learner i
also recognize that there are people who
need the language for professional
reasons
because they want to get into a school
so that they're not just
dabbling in the language exploring
having fun like i like to do they
actually need it
so how good do they need to be in the
language well
first of all there is an expression many
of you have heard and
an expression that exists in many
languages
the perfect can be the enemy of the good
so
if you try to be perfect you may end up
not being very good
if you are too obsessed with being
perfect you might
not communicate as well as someone else
who is simply trying to communicate
without worrying about being perfect
because
you know speaking a foreign language is
not like
being in the diving competition at the
olympic games
uh it's not like designing a rocket
that's going to go to the moon or
building a bridge
there we have to be perfect even if
you're building a simple structure
you've got to have 90 degree angles
things have to be straight there's no
room for sloppiness however in
communicating in the language there's
lots of room for sloppiness
you can still communicate you can still
understand so how good do we need to be
first of all in my experience
as a person who has worked with people
from many different countries where
sometimes we speak english and sometimes
we speak
the other person's native language
rarely rarely have i
dealt with people who spoke english
perfectly it didn't matter whether they
were swedish german french spanish
japanese chinese
if they were speaking english
there was always something there with
which suggested that they weren't native
speakers
similarly when i speak those languages
they know that i'm not a native speaker
however we are comfortable communicating
with each other
i do think that
the standard required for written
communication
is usually higher than the standard
required for oral communication
uh
use of words uh
some aspects of grammar i think we're
more willing to forgive
in spoken uh you know conversations than
we are if you get a formal letter you
know extreme example would be some legal
letter or whatever but even a contract
uh there i think we have to be a little
more careful
and
the fact that we sort of give up on the
idea of being perfect in other words
speaking with no accent making no
mistakes
we recognize that we're not going to
achieve that
but that doesn't prevent us from wanting
to continue to improve
so the question is you know how do we
continue to improve
so
uh and bear in mind that people who have
you know i think of henry kissinger who
you know you can still hear his german
accent after gosh i don't know how many
years of working at the highest level of
diplomacy in the english language so
once we recognize that there are limits
to how good we can become
i think the question then is how do we
become better because we would all like
to be better we would all like to
continue to improve
and there i think the the the issue is
we have to be so comfortable so natural
in the language that without thinking
about it we start to speak
more
correctly we start to use words and very
often it's more a matter of use of words
than
nitty points nitty bitty nitpicking
points of grammar and i mean you won't
be surprised to hear me say that that
just requires an awful lot of reading
and listening and
particularly reading if we want to write
well let's say we have a job
for a company that's uh deals in english
and we're writing uh you know commercial
correspondence you have to read a lot of
that kind of material so that you end up
gradually naturally using words and
using phrases and structures and
terminology the way
very proficient users of that language
do
i think it can help and link to save key
phrases that are very natural very
powerful that other people have used so
that we're imitating these
very good models of how to use the
language
and i think if we want to get closer to
if not perfection a very high standard
in the language i think it's important
to focus on our ability to write the
language accurately to use words
accurately and when you are writing you
have time to think about what you want
to say you have time to look words up
you have time to look even grammar rules
up and gradually develop you know habits
that will carry over into your speaking
and so the sort of emphasis should be on
you know use of the language
not necessarily on how well you
pronounce there's nothing wrong with
wanting to work on improving or making
the the pronunciation more native-like
but it's not as important and i think
we've all had the experience of dealing
with foreigners you know as an english
speaker foreigners who use english very
very well but have an accent and we're
almost more impressed with those people
because they have an accent and yet they
use our language so elegantly so
accurately so powerfully and if we're
able to do that in a foreign language
even with an accent that's fine i wanted
to talk about people who have a need to
perform in the language
and what is a realistic expectation and
i don't think that perfection is a
realistic expectation but constant
improvement the willingness to
constantly improve and the desire to
constantly engage with the language
those are the things that that will keep
us moving forward i look forward to
hearing from you